[Music]
Let There Be dragons and L behold
dragons there be so if you're thinking
what's up with this dude talking crazy
over here well House of the Dragon has
just released its first teaser for its
second season and boy oh boy do we
already have quite a lot to talk about
but since we here are mainly a big
monster Channel we will focus more on
the creatures and at the same time
insert a thing or two about the dance of
the Dragons storyline so for this video
right here we will discuss all the
dragons that have appeared in the teaser
as well as the scenes that confirm the
other unseen dragons so let's get to it
firstly the scene of Adam of Hull and
sea smoke so as the teer trailer went on
the first sighting of a dragon was of
sea smoke
the dragon that was seen in the early
episodes of season 1 and then just
disappeared later on anyway after Leno
valarian faked his death and went
eastwards towards a new life sea smoke
was left rless and therefore a new trial
of dragon seeds will commence whereby
Adam of Hull will Bor and Rite the Smoky
ashy dragon and claim him as his own
number two the scene of Cyrax and rera
meeting sea smoke and Adam of Hull so
the this is the second sighting of
dragons and it is that of rera Taran
along with her Dragon Cyrax meeting the
Adam of Hull who has mastered and bonded
with sea smoke just as a great guy on
Instagram named Cen predicted sea smoke
is a little bigger and longer than Cyrax
his judgment and Analysis is proven
correct here in this scene rera will
have a conversation with Adam of Hull
and reveal to him that he is in fact a
valarian bastard and if he so chooses to
site with her he will be legitimized as
the heir to drift Mark along with his
brother Alan of Hull number three the
next here is the scene in the battle at
rook's rest which shows soldiers being
bathed in dragon fire so the Infantry
here are of the greens meaning the ones
who will fight for Aon Taran aegon II
and the high Towers therefore as by the
books the only dragon of the blacks that
will be seen here in this battle will be
melees the Red Queen ritten by Princess
rainers spoilers alert the battle here
won't just be people being burnt alive
by flying creatures it will also have
the first major Dragon on Dragon Battle
and this will be between melees and
Sunfire and then vagar coming in
afterwards to make the fight a two
onone number four the scene of Moon
Dancer written by Baylor Baya Targaryen
this scene here while it doesn't really
show the dragon shows the rider on top
of the saddle holding on and trying to
navigate the dragon this person here is
Baya Targaryen the daughter of Damon
Targaryen and a dragon in question is
Moon Dancer which is going to be a young
Beast about the size of aax at his time
of death number five Dragon seeds being
burnt by the wild dragons so in the
scene we see a group of people being
burnt alive these will be Dragon seeds
who are men which are gearing blood in
them illegitimate bastards and distant
relatives that have their blood lessened
by marriage with the people of wus they
will be trying to mount and born with
the wild dragons in Dragon Stone to help
even the odds of the black dragons
forces they the wild dragons here are
probably GRE host sheep stealer and
cannibal or just one of
these number six Damon tararan on top of
Caris or maybe it's vermithor then we
have good old demon on top of his Dragon
Caris in this scene but is it really
Caris here remember
in the last episode of the first season
we actually saw Damon trying to woo and
communicate with an old vermithor a
dragon that has been resting without a
rider for a long time it's not
unreasonable to say that Damon in his
life has had quite a few meetings with
the dragon veror who was once his great
grandfather's Dragon therefore vermar
might allow him to mount him but it
won't be a permanent thing the reason I
come into this conclusion is that this
saddle right here is vastly different
from the Sal used to write a serpentine
Caris anyway it could either be one of
the two dragons Caris is an always be
Damon's Bor but as we have seen in Game
of Thrones a dragon can still allow
others to approach it and number seven
Amon on top of vagar of course lastly we
see Amon on top of vagar soaring the
skies above rook's rest probably giving
morale to the soldiers of the greens
this scene here shows just how big vagar
is compared to all the other dragons her
size is just tremendous and a sight to
see the next in size is vermar of course
which although big isn't close to the
size of this old dragon that has seen
the days of aegon's Conquest so if you
like this video then watch this other
one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie monsters and
creatures then check out our Channel
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam